welcome back to pj chain design today i
would like to
take some time to show you every single
part
of this design and how to build them
in rhino are you ready let's get started
that's starting with bringing one stone
and if you wanted to
know how to make this stone i have the
link on the right top corner
or um you can download there's a link at
the description before
below okay so we want to make the c for
this one so i'm going to
just create a cylinder underneath it and
we want the cylinder
um not to be bigger than this
usually but um in this case since i'm
going to do the cluster
so i might need to make it a little bit
bigger so here's what i'm going to do
in the stone setting you don't want to
have a cooler which is the point of the
stone is sticky out
and we also want to cut it this taper so
i simply just want to have a bevel h
so let's go ahead to try the bevel 4.4
and let's click on this edge inside so
then uh your jeweler doesn't have to cut
a lot
basically a lot of time i do not want
the seat to be see on the top i have
more information about why and there's a
reason
in my storm setting class but in this
case i want them to be just a little bit
bigger it's because we're gonna do the
cluster setting
all right so then we are going to design
the prong
you could have this getting a little bit
longer if you want to
and we can trim it all at once if that
work better for you
but it's really up to you for how long
you want it as long as
the cooler does not stick it out that's
really important part
let's go ahead to make a prong i'm going
to draw just a straight line
coming just a little bit over the uh
table and then uh coming down something
like this
and then we are going to use the pipe
command let's go ahead to pipe it
for what do you think it's a proper size
in my case i'm going to have something
like this
i usually don't want to have the stone
cutting
more than 20 25 then the prong is
because
the prong is gonna get into weak
and we are going to use the polar array
and let's try the polar array
and i'm going to hit 0 as my
center and i want to have six of them
and i will get something like this
so i'm going to change the strong into
other layer
and change to other color as well so
it's easier for you to see
all right so now we have the stone there
we are going to do the cluster so i'm
going
to just temporarily to group on
everybody because i don't know
if that is what i'm going to have i
might need to adjust the prong at this
point
next things i wanted to do is i want to
making a copy
roughly about this you can make the
stone the same size or you want to make
them
smaller it's up to you but i like to
tilt it this one and move it down a
little bit
like this so that will be my first uh
stone for
the cluster i may want to moving in a
little bit or tilt it
or make it lower whichever you think the
position is going to look nice
watch out something over here you do not
want it to prompt to be stick together
it won't look nice
so we want to get it as close as
possible but do not want to have the
prong like
100 percent stick together it's hard
like what i have here
it's hard for your jewelry to set so
make sure you have a little bit distance
there
all right so now we have this one let's
give it a try we're going to do polar
array
and we're going to have six of them and
that's recorder history just in case
we want to move them all right so make
sure that everything is looks
nice there uh in this case i
sometimes like to do have a center stone
is a little bit bigger
but it's up to you for what you'd like
to do let me try this to
make the center stone a little bit
bigger so that filling the space much
better um but it's up to you for what
you like to do
so now this is the center for my cluster
so if everything look okay we're going
to
stop here and we're going to work on the
rest of it
next i wanted to do is do the design
like outside
of those stone and we are going to using
the start command make sure the number
is
equal six of them and i want them to be
something look like this
and coming into inside something look
like this
all right and make sure that they fit it
really well
and we are going to use the command it's
called fitted corners
and let's try something a little bit big
like three here
so we'll get this over here now if it is
touching
you can you know enlarge if you want to
i want to keep it like this first and
see how that goes with the
rest of the stuff and we want to move it
down for whatever the position is going
to be
so somewhere like this will be
what i have there next we wanted to know
what is the size of a stone is going to
be
set there i say i'm going to copy this
stone
to the top on my top view i'm going to
scale down this stone
and somewhere about 2 millimeter
or less and this is just a guideline for
us to know where the stone is going to
sit
i'm also want to see the side view and
see if it is
if i'm moving this one back to here
without touching whether it be too much
of a space or something like that
and you can consider to make this
smaller
bigger whichever that fit into your
design
and i'm going to stay like this i'm
roughly wanting to know what size of my
stone
is in a reality most of the time you
know your stone size
before you actually make them so you
have to make
to fit your stone and the demonstration
i'm just go by aesthetic and see which
one look nice
so the stone is roughly about 1.7
millimeter
i'm going to offset this guy
to be two millimeter and so i'm going to
offset twice that's once that's
two so that's showing where the boundary
is going to be this
one in the middle it's for me it's going
to
arrange my stone but i do want them to
be
kind of tapered a little bit so i'm
going to move the outer one
down like this and then going to use the
command
for loft and we're gonna loft from here
to here
and so that will be the surface for our
stone to sit on
and of course you see the stone and
stick it out like this
so i'm going to move it the stone
roughly
close to the surface there and also want
to move it down
so this is how my stone is going to sit
and if it is
not following well we're just gonna
manually to move it
down something like this okay so
the proper way to sit the stone i have a
lot of explanation
in my stone setting class but in this
case i'm just gonna quickly
to talk about it you want a girdle to be
sit flat with your surface
that's basically what we are looking for
okay so let's give it a try
we're going to use the array tool
we're going to array along curve and
let's pick up the stone
hit enter and we're going to pick up the
path and which is the one in the middle
how many do we need it i don't know i'm
just guessing maybe
28 and
you want to make sure that the gap that
you have
in between depends on what type of prong
you're going to put it whether you're
going to use the shear prong
or you're going to have full prong for
each of a stone
and i would like to have a shared prong
so maybe i want to get the stone a
little bit closer
so 30 and let's try
32 okay so 32
look nice in my song setting class i
also talk about the
the distance in between i usually like
to have 0.1 millimeter of 2.2 millimeter
uh you cannot get it zero um it's
because the stone never coming into
exact size
so you need to have uh some tolerance
for it
all right so 32 look nice for the share
pro
so i'm going to stop there and that will
be my stone
arrangement so that's now making prong
there
i'm going to use uh the straight line
and again i'm going to coming over here
we don't need to be
too long on the bottom because it's
going to be trim
off and i'm going to pipe it this one
and we are going to
try the radius for 0.35
and see if the prong size look alright i
mean you look huge
on the side view but if you look at the
top view
it looks something like this and we want
to moving
our prong over here to see if that fit
it well
and double make sure that you wanted to
have a prong touching the stone
on both sides you do not want them to be
only touching on one side
make sure that it's not cutting too much
something like this
the prong will break for sure so we want
to coming back
and make sure it's touching on the both
side okay
and we want to make a copy over there
roughly something like this
and again you want to make sure it's
touching on the both side
sometimes if it is the space is usually
in the inner side of this prong
it's a little bit too small then you can
make the
prong size smaller if you want to i
usually keep it the same um
and also maybe enlarge this one and if
you are interesting about
what size of a stone for what size of a
pro i have a
the whole discussion in my course as
well i don't want to spend too much time
here i want to show you something else
all right so now we get it really close
to inside
then we have something like that double
double check
if that look all right to you i'm going
to move them into
other layer and change to other colors
as well so it's easier for you to see
all right so now this is my prong and
then if that look all right to you we
are going to pick up both of them
and let's go ahead to use exactly the
same number
coming into the transform array a long
curve
and we are going to pick up the same
curve and the same number for 32
so now this is what we get for the prong
all right double check if
any of the prong is not in the right
place
if everything looks okay to you we are
going to turn this surface
into the solid there are two way to make
it into the solid
first you can coming into the solid you
have extruded surface and then you can
extrude it straight
and you can pick up the surface and you
can extrude it if you don't like this
direction
you can actually coming into the
direction here
and you can using your mouse to tell
like what direction you want them to go
so let's say we want them to go like
this so that's
one way to extrude it and um
but kind of notice that it's extruded
into the angle here but the same angle
there
the other option you have is when you
extruded
surface then you want them to be tapered
so you pick up this surface
and you want to taper it down for
whatever degree you're going to have
so that way it will be the correct
extrusion so you
they won't like tilt it on the on the
side all right
so that's one way to do it the other way
that you can do
you can actually just using the offset
surface
and we can pick up this surface
and we want to offset so now it's offset
to the top we want to flip
all of them down and the distance i want
to
say 0.85 is actually pretty good
distance
so that way we can offset that as well
it's similar like taper
the taper you can choose the angle for
it the offset they will just
automatically calculate it
all right so now we have all the part
ready and
i will suggest you to do one thing is to
fill the edges because when it whenever
you fill
the edges it will look much nicer on a
rendering so we are going to try a small
fillet
and let's try here here here and here
especially outside edges anything like
anywhere that you can see you want to
fill it
but since we are going to fill it let's
go ahead to fill
every single edges there and i'm gonna
pick up all four of them
alright so if we take a look on the
render you can see
it's much nicer it's rounded there back
to the ghost view
all right so how do we do the bottom one
to be
those like uh web looking things so i'm
coming into the front view
i'm going to draw a line simply going to
go
somewhere like here here
coming over to be something like this
and if you don't like the the shape
you can change it if you want to and now
i'm in looking at this one double make
sure they are flat this
curve is flat so let me create another
layer change that
curve into other objects so i can turn
this off
it's easier for us to see see it is not
flat
and the reason it's not flat is because
it was snapping
into all snap into the object
all we need to do is coming into the
front view
use the commands for projector to cplane
and we want to delete input so now you
see it's flat
okay so i'm going to turn it back on
that one because we will need this curve
so let me grab that and change the layer
as well
okay so now you can see we have
this curve and we also have this for
rail
to making a surface we wanted to do
is to do rail revolve and we are going
to pick up this one
the rail is this one and the axis
is actually snapping into the zero
i'm gonna draw a line just holding my
shift and click on this
and so then you will get this surface
there all right
beautiful surface and we're going to use
this surface to creating our curve
now there are so many lines over there
so i'm going to do
it's to rebuild this line to be even
on the top i'm going to do 12 of them
the bottom it doesn't matter if you
wanted to have your cage have a more
line
you may want to do more like 24 whatever
so let's say maybe 18 of them and see
what happened
so it's evenly out for 18 of them uh you
can have
one stone every one stone have
one line there so since we have 32 stone
you can change here to
32 if you want to but i think it's just
too many curve so i'm going to do maybe
2 24 and make sure that your degree is 3
and 3
and let's click ok all right so now we
have this curve
let me go ahead to hiding everybody
first beside
our surface so it's not get too confused
see always lie there and we need to have
those lines for us to do the piping
so coming into the curve you have the
curve on the object
you have extract wireframe
so then we're gonna click up this one
now we can delete our surface see all
those beautiful lines that we can use
for piping so i'm gonna
delete this one did it that one okay so
let's go ahead to pick up
everybody we are going to use the pipe
command
and let's pipe it not something like a
way too fat
so 0.35 on the radius over there
this will be our nest in the back
so let me turn on the rest of it let's
take a look
notice that this is a little bit
too wide we should you know check on it
before we
actually pipe it uh one thing you can do
is you can pick up all your pipe
coming to the top we can scale it down
something like this this is like 2d
scale
put it like here and double check
if they look alright okay so now
look like this is a little bit ugly
inside of it
so we are going to hiding this piping
things over here
let's go ahead to pick up all the thing
right here
and let's do the bowling union there so
if
everything looks all right to you you're
not gonna changing then we're gonna do
the bullying unit it say it will break
your history that's okay
and we also wanted to trim it so i'm
going to draw a big box
right there and bring down a little bit
for whatever
we are going to cut and let's go ahead
to use a bowling difference
this out of this one
all right and let's bring back to the
cage there
all right so it looked nice over there
however
remember this one and this one
it's not touching yet all right so we
need to make sure it's touching
i mean the design can be um really 3d
for what you like to do for them to
touch sometimes it's
important for polish and that means i
mean
all of this might be casting in one
piece
and all of the rest of them will cast in
other piece
so that way you can polish inside and
then you can solder
this one back to here so all you need to
do is design some sort of a key there so
you could have
design a puzzle and that will
puzzle this piece and this piece back
together
so that way um you can polish inside
after that you can put the jump ring and
you can put the bell and then
that will be this design with the
cluster setting and b
setting on the side for this pendant i
hope you enjoy the video there's
a lot more trick and tips in my
membership program
hope you enjoy let me know what you
think thank you for watching
see you next
[Music]
you